في المانيا اصيبت المطارات وايضا محطات
الحافلات والقطارات بالشلل وذلك في جميع
انحاء البلاد هناك هذا اليوم وذلك خلال
احد اكبر الاضرابات منذ عقود مما تسبب في
ارباك ملايين الاشخاص في بدايه اسبوع
العمل هذا الاضراب ياتي في وقت تعاني فيه
المانيا وهي صاحبه اكبر اقتصاد في اوروبا
تعاني من التضخم طبعا الاضراب المقرر لمده
24 ساعه دعت له نقابات عماليه وهو الاحدث
في اضرابات مستمره لشهور اضرت بالاقتصادات
الاوروبيه الكبرى حيث اثر ارتفاع اسعار
الغذاء والطاقه على مستويات المعيشه وقد
علقت ناني من اكبر المطارات في المانيا
وهما ميونخ وفرانكفورت الرحله الجويه في
حين الغت الشركه المشغله لخدمات السكك
الحديديه رحلات المسافات الطويله